longview washington voted one of
america's prettiest towns is home to
pacific northwest jewel the monticello
hotel built in 1923 this historic
building is currently celebrating its
90th anniversary but unlike cheese and
good wine some things do not get better
with age
oh my gosh
i'm philip lovingplus and i'm the owner
of the monticello hotel i've wanted to
own the hotel since i was eight years
old my mother worked here when i was
very young and i remember all the
cocktail waitresses and how beautiful
they were and wanted to be a part of it
some might say the story of how philip
loving foster obtained the hotel is
almost too good to be true others might
call it a fairy tale philip was a
bartender here he fell in love with the
owner annabelle jewell i was in my early
30s when annabelle and i first started
going together and she was in her mid
60s
they were married and when annabelle
passed away all of her assets
were given to phillip
he inherited the monticello hotel
how pretty
with his inheritance philip has been
living the good life with his girlfriend
and general manager ginger who is also
30 years a senior
dj but despite the owners fabulous
wealth the staff are underpaid i still
make minimum wage and i've been here 12
years
yay we're getting it
yeah phillip flaunts his wealth in front
of us don't flaunt it in our face when
we're all wondering do we put gas in the
car or do we buy groceries
this is [ __ ] unreal
he's probably got 150 000 worth of
diamonds on his right arm 10 carat
diamond ring on his left finger he
walked through the kitchen one day and
and somebody broke a glass and he said
oh do i lose a stone
i mean really how [ __ ] arrogant i
want to say [ __ ] you
while philip and ginger have been
enjoying their wealth the hotel has been
terribly neglected
cigarette burns oh my gosh
seriously that is so gross
i'll go all the way down the hall around
the corner inside the beautiful historic
monticello hotel there are only four
suites and then there are countless
rooms stuffed with phillip and ginger's
crap instead of guests
with only four guest bedrooms available
in the main hotel most guests are
unwittingly given rooms in the so-called
north wing which is a character-less
1960s shoebox motel next door i was
hoping to stay in the hotel i don't
really even feel like staying here now
and having been ignored for years the
hotel is not generating any new business
with a rapidly dwindling client base
where's mary she's not here with us
this once glamorous hotel has major
problems
but philip's problem may be the biggest
it is no big secret that philip drinks
phillip will come in here drunk good job
good job in front of all the staff
and it's just an embarrassing mess
i think that philip could die he doesn't
stop drinking
[Music]
it scares me the day before i arrived in
longview things reached crisis point
i was pulled over
and they charged me with a dui
i was
placed under arrest they booked me in
the callus county jail and yesterday
morning i was released it's an
unfortunate situation
thank you you guys have a good night
this hotel its staff and the community
deserve better
phil talk about closing it
if gordon isn't able to save this place
for us um 50 people will be out of jobs
and phil will be on his yacht in seattle
drunk hey nasa
this place is a gem
that needs to be preserved it's the
heart of longview
this town needs the monticello
[Music]
gorgeous that place is massive
look at all those rooms for guests
finally somewhere nice to stay i feel
sorry for the crappy motel next door i'm
amazed that place is still open right
next to a big hotel like that my god
[Music]
wow look at those beautiful cars there
must be a car show on oh no somebody
having a laugh
hotel hell
ladies night who the [ __ ] can't spell
part-time housekeeper i can't do
anything worse to advertise on the
outside of your hotel
good morning good morning and first name
is vanessa vanessa nice to see you i'm
going i see you're having a classic car
show today no those all belong to our
owner phillip
no stop they do
they belong to the owner
what's with the plate there's like hotel
hell on one of the plates yes but you
did that for me i'm not sure if he did
it for you or for him wow
uh jeff daggie employer of the month
2010. you know it's
2013. i do yes other stuff that bad that
hasn't been
a more recent employee of the month last
i heard actually he was in jail
holy crap
we have so many great employees it's
ridiculous that we're not recognized
more than we are here's your card and
here is your room code you're in room
220 are we showing the way or oh sure if
you'd like shall we please if you follow
me i'll get that we're going outside yes
okay just across here so you have to go
out to get back up again yes
then 220 right here
um but this is not the hotel this is our
north wing motel
now why in the [ __ ] would i want to stay
in here
all we have available to rent in the
hotel are four suites
i'd rather stay in there next door okay
than in this dump i'm sorry people want
to stay in the hotel they don't want to
stay in the cracker box driving up here
i didn't expect to be put in a motel no
i understand and i'm i am sorry
all right it's just right over here
thank you you're welcome bloody hell
that sofa's the hideous who would use a
[ __ ] brown circle like that
oh my god it gets worse in here this bed
is this auntie uh no the rooms are
furnished completely with stuff from
philip and jinger's home oh dear there's
a mattress from their house yes
you bring a mattress from your house
into your hotel i wouldn't
they charge 250 a night for that
mattress i don't even know what to say
about it when they get new stuff they
bring old stuff here
there's some storage rooms that are full
of old furniture where the storage
places work
geez it's like a suite just full of crap
it's like a dumping ground
there's more too wow you are kidding me
you're not oh my god look at this
i wish i was kidding
it's like a hoarder it's just junk
everywhere i don't understand how delano
they would dump half their ship in hotel
rooms and not rent them out gordon was
pretty appalled at the state of the
storage rooms how much crap there was in
there it's just a big [ __ ] waste
i appreciate it thank you
wow this place is so disappointing the
biggest highlight so far is the drive up
the minute you step inside it's just
bizarre i can't wait to meet the owner
and find out what the hell is going on
in his head
i've just arrived at the monticello
hotel in longview washington and i'm
shocked to discover that there are only
four rooms for guests in this grand
place while others are being used for
storage oh my god it's like a hoarder
it's just junk everywhere
i've got to meet the owner and the
general manager and figure out what else
is wrong with this place
hello nice to see you very nice to see
you welcome to the monticello thank you
what a gorgeous place from the outside
thank you how are you good so you're
ginger yes this is my significant other
hello
there you go is that true that's true
wow look at that bling have a quick look
it looks like a super bowl ring
too heavy for me um i thought there was
a car
fair here so someone told me they're
yours nevermind amazing
let's go to the lounge
did you always want to own a hotel ever
since i was a little kid i wanted to go
in this hotel
and what's the building worth now
between probably three and five million
it's extraordinary i inherited it
all the estate yes and if you don't want
me asking what was that the tune of i
didn't know yet
well is the hotel making money or losing
money who's losing that i've been
carrying it how much you're losing
uh 30 to 35 000 a month
losing that's like 400 a year
that's insane there's lots of sleepless
nights for me how are we losing so much
money i didn't take advantage of i know
that who's taking advantage the kitchen
staff for sure
they wait and leave the clock
do you think you can get paid for hours
that you're not working they can't do
that to you
i think gordon's gonna have difficulties
with my employees i don't see them as
team players at all if this place was
taken away what would it mean to you
devastated it would be equivalent to a
death oh geez i started here in 1973
this has been a huge part of my life wow
well let's give me an insight let me
tell you um ginger nice to see you lana
very nice
thank you thank you thank you thanks so
much
thank you so much
it's terrible to hear that philip and
ginger are being taken advantage of by
their staff when they clearly care so
much i really hope i can help them sort
their employees out
oh hello good evening how are you i'm
fine i'm debbie debbie gould nice to see
you i have a table for you right over
here now how long have we been here i
have been here 12 years wow seriously 12
years yes
um uh right what would you recommend i
recommend
our crab and artichoke dip okay let's
get one of those all right
philips triple tower yes what's that
it's a three-tier tower of three
different appetizers and is his name big
enough on the menu there obviously
suffering from small man's syndrome
let's go for that and then the button at
ravioli let's try that all right thanks
nice to see
so the appetizers first please okay
i'm feeling really nervous about cooking
for gordon they're all [ __ ] froze
together most of the food is
pre-packaged or canned or frozen because
ginger and philip are running this place
like real misers they uh pinch a penny
on every corner
this is our crab and artichoke dip it's
served with deep fried pita bread and um
is it fresh crab or canned frozen chili
and crab frozen chili and crab correct
jesus
[ __ ] snot dip
yeah i mean it's like a dish ready for
one of philip's girlfriends no teeth oh
god it's got that sour taste to it i
don't know what it is
no jesus thanks daddy
ah
he felt it tasted sour it always got
that taste to me i don't like it
you are kidding me
off the tower this is the tower this is
the tower oh my god holy mackerel so
no but it's like something you should
have in your [ __ ] garden not in your
restaurant are they shrimp are they
fresh are they frozen they're frozen
they're frozen damn
[Music]
it's [ __ ] disgusting
and what's in here they're teriyaki beef
tips
jesus
that sauce is hideous and that's just
tough
beef tips it's like beef chew
and that middle one's another portion of
snot dip i'll skip that well
unfortunately for the chef he doesn't
get to dictate his own menu
what
the chef doesn't write his own menu he
does not
let's move on shall we my god careful
so philip's dictating the menu i suppose
if his staff can't be trusted to clock
in and out they can't be trusted to
choose the food
feedback on that um the meat is too
tough the sauce tastes weird he can tell
it's not homemade
is this
ramses and it is the meat is too tough
he's getting the full picture and that's
just what i wanted
[Music]
right feel very good about it i am very
disappointed with dan's food it's
horrible
i just hope that gordon sees the
problems with the staff
ravioli
[Music]
i'm dreading bringing this dish out to
him right now the butternut wrap really
thank you
who made the raviolis i don't know the
name of the manufacturer manufacturer
correct so the rubber is not even made
either they are not made here oh jesus
they're packaged
[Music]
that's dreadful like a mouthful of sugar
every time
oh dear
thank you dang
wow
frozen crab frozen shrimp pre-packaged
ravioli it's more like eating a badly
run old folks home than a decent
restaurant
obviously from a package
we all knew that one was coming
i think there's a better way that our
kitchen can function than it's
functioning right now
i see this blatant neglect
um tell me about philips management
style well when he's sober i get along
with him just fine
when he's drinking i avoid him at all
costs
does he drink a lot on site
he does well scala wanted 10 how bad is
he drinking now a
this week he was arrested
for what do you like
you are [ __ ] kidding me i'm not
kidding
oh my god i want to see a hotel owner
jailed jailed
he was kept overnight in jail
bloody hell
why would he not tell me that when it
just happened
hours ago
philip's in denial he doesn't take
responsibility for this drinking problem
and i felt gordon needed to know
oh [ __ ]
the truth is starting to come out
um why don't you ask the chef to come
out of the dining room i'd like to meet
him and bring philip and ginger as well
thank you
he would like to see you all in the
dining room
[Music]
all right
i'm not for words chef that was dreadful
i don't think anything was fresh
it takes extra time to do things
homemade uh yeah naturally we're on a
time restraint what ask how many hours
they get in a week or whatever and they
gotta scrape for out
my prep cook gets 20 hours a week
that's not enough time to make fresh
food is that why all the food's frozen i
mean i get cut carrots or cut celery in
the bag i get the boiled eggs in a bag
done peeled you buy in boiled eggs yes
i played the safe card and
purchased most of it prepared you played
the safe card we can't even boil a
[ __ ] egg in here philip if you care
about quality you need to pay people to
prep fresh food not buy it in there were
times uh
through january february where i'd have
12 16 hours a week
a week yeah how did you survive
three hours a day
not very well do you have a family yes i
do dan serving kids
this is insane
you can't run this hotel like a miser
if i sold [ __ ] three of those cars
and put it into the kitchen budget to
function for the next 12 months the
chefs can do their job
and speaking of cars why don't you tell
me about this
i'm at the monticello hotel in longview
washington oh my god i want to see the
hotel island jailed jailed and i've just
discovered that the hotel owner has a
drinking problem so bad that just one
day before i arrived he was arrested for
drunk driving
can i have a word with the owner
please yes
what's going on
truthfully
have you had a drink today no
yes you have
your staff
tell me that you have a drinking problem
no
and yet you've just been busted
for dui
ginger
does your boyfriend have a drinking
problem
he does like his libations
i'm pissed off that you couldn't even
say hey gordon can have a word gordon i
fully intended on having a conversation
all over the newspaper
i'm aware of that
who owns this place me so when are you
gonna step up
i'm here gordon
i'm engaged if you can't be honest with
yourself
you're [ __ ]
[Music]
the facts are starting to become clear
the problem here isn't the staff it's
the owner you have um
room service we do not
no room service in a hotel this size
that's not the only unpleasant surprise
guests check in and just like me they
think they're going to get a room in a
historic gym but instead they're placed
in the motel
i don't think i could shower in this i
wonder if we can ask for a different
room this is awful
and a fettuccine alfredo's ready and
during dinner service most of the guests
are over the age of 17. there clearly
hasn't been any buzz about this place in
decades yes
sir prime rib it should be a little
moister in that shouldn't it well i
could go i can go and check and see if
there's another ingot back there dan
yeah do we have another end cut a moist
one please be juicy
it is
okay
is flipping do you do this no no why all
of a sudden is he involved
because i'm here i'm sorry
strawberry daiquiri
i can't believe philip is put on a show
for me
well if you want to know the truth about
a drinker ask the bartender
grant that's why it's going on tonight
it's like a comedy of heroes here you're
welcome does philip normally act tonight
no no
what does philip normally do at the
hotel he does drink quite a bit
well and on average a day how many
drinks would you make a day during the
day sometimes four or five and then it
jumps into the evening
it could come up to uh
7 8.
i had them cut off a new one oh wow wow
no wonder things are on the slide with
philip drinking that much i've got to
get him to tell me the truth
this
monstrous hotel has been running
rudderless there's no one at the helm
and you're pretending all of a sudden
i'm busy i make some time lifting
because i'm here i i just no it's not
because you're here you don't normally
do this stuff this is what i normally do
you're calling your staff liars i would
say so if they say that i'm not out here
helping them every time i walk in this
building i would call them [ __ ] liars
[Music]
be [ __ ] honest with me i am yeah do
you think i can just wave a [ __ ]
magic wand when the place is running to
the ground
[Music]
with dinner service over
i'm gonna get philip and his staff
together so i can finally get to the
truth
[Music]
is that normal what i witnessed tonight
is philip always here
does philip always expedite the [ __ ]
hot plate no no
we need somebody to expedite we're
understaffed and if we get busy then we
can't give good service and those people
will not come back a person can't
shortcut like that he's trying to this
place the business has been strangled
he's been strangled by the owner
why are we pretending
i'm doing a good job of pretending then
this is what i do every time that you
come in here this is what you do i do
not run food down to your bar for the
last couple nights
let's talk about
the elephant in the room shall we
when
philip's drinking he behaves one or two
different ways either
he's jovial and
likes to giggle and have a good time or
if finances are
in arrears that we hear about how much
everything cost you and you're going to
close the doors it's stressful it's not
easy to come to work with someone
threatening us all the time that the
doors are going to be closed please
don't look at me like that phillip
because you do do this to us
that's [ __ ]
you need to know the truth
you have told us over and over and over
again that you're just going to i may i
may have said that twice
twice but come in here regularly and say
i'm gonna close the doors if we keep
lying about [ __ ] and we keep covering up
[ __ ] and whatever then he ain't gonna
[ __ ] help us and here we go like this
like we've been going for seven [ __ ]
years
he's he's been known to walk behind the
bar and fix himself drinks after the
staff cuts them off
yes
is that true
that i don't know about
that i don't know about i've gone behind
the bar and made my own drinks yes so
you're blacked out you're that inebrated
that you've got no [ __ ] idea that
you're that far gone if he goes behind
the bar take the drink away from him he
cannot go is he in there in the first
place why is he even in that bar in the
first place why is he drinking why do
that to me it's hypocritical you put out
memos saying that we can't drink in the
bar it's hypocritical philip and we care
about this place and we care about you
but a lot of us feel like you don't give
a damn about us
why are you coming in here to put your
your employees in a bad uncomfortable
situation if it was up to me i'd say
philip you can't drink in here because
if something happens to you take out a
family of four they're coming after me
and my family
and i don't have any money to afford a
lawyer to keep me out of jail for the
rest of my life
i'm at the monticello hotel in longview
washington where the staff are
confronting the owner about his drinking
problem if it was up to me i'd say
philip you can't drink in here because
if something happens to you take out a
family of four they're coming after me
in my family
and i don't have any money to afford a
lawyer to keep me out of jail for the
rest of my life
they are telling you the truth because
they fricking care
unfortunately you're not telling the
truth
and that's why this business is
struggling
this ship is on a collision course
can i show you something i think you
should all see come with me
[Music]
i think everybody's forgotten what it's
like for guests to stay in this hotel
dan
april how much is this room 250 a night
friday and saturday is 180 the rest of
the week let me show you what 250 gets
you at the monticello go turn the lights
out
you see that this black light shows up
bodily fluids
that's exactly what you're seeing i
wouldn't want to lay on that bed where
these mattresses come from philly the
house in arizona your house yes wow
those two holes there
that's cigarette holes uh-oh burns
watch out it's everywhere don't touch
them
i was totally grossed out when i seen
that bed it was sickening 250
to sleep in phil
oh my god
phillips semen right there is everywhere
does that make anybody else feel sick
yeah because right now
i am [ __ ] disgusted by this foul
polluted bed
i felt dirty i'm a clean person it was
disgusting i don't know why you're
running a hotel
you're just ripping people off you don't
care
for the customers and you don't care for
your staff who do you care for
i care about my style
the first thing you said to me when i
arrived here philip what's the problem
staff
they're bleeding the clock
no way
that's what you told me i've got half it
wrote down at home where i put at least
100 hours free in here
we will come in an hour two hours early
not punch in and then we will work late
to get what we need to get done
you have an estate to the tune of ten
[ __ ] million dollars and a chef that
was a hundred hours in for nothing
or is he lying he's not lying he's here
all the time
i'm surprised you guys are here
i'm the only earner for my family
and
i make 500 bucks every two weeks this is
[ __ ] crazy
[Music]
and you rock up here with a plate with
hotel hell
what the [ __ ] is going on
these guys are your bread and butter
your [ __ ] backbone but they're
terrified to tell you the truth you'll
keep on cutting corners
and humiliating them because
they're the problem the fact that it's
not busy look within it starts from the
[ __ ] top amen yeah
can you just excuse me and leave me here
on my own with philip thank you
now can you [ __ ] your man up i don't
have all the answers gordon i'm trying
give me one [ __ ] answer give me
something
you're abusing your staff
what kind of message does it send to
them
when you fill the car park with classic
cars and they're [ __ ] struggling
drinking is fair
but i think it's fair enough no
do they deserve better
of course why are you doing it
i don't have an answer for that i don't
know why i'm doing that
gal foreign leave me alone
get the [ __ ] out of here
[Music]
man
that was rough sleeping in a tub is
bloody uncomfortable but it certainly
beats sleeping on that filthy mattress
[Music]
the staff have been as honest as they
can be but they're all afraid of losing
their jobs
both you come with me please it's time
philip and ginger heard from the people
who aren't afraid to tell them the truth
hi good morning everybody good morning
thank you so much for coming
your guest i'm going to give you some
honest feedback
that room was dirty it looked like an
animal was killed and drug out the room
i mean this stain goes down the hall
there's no thought to the guest
experience at all wow you feel like you
threw your money down the drain
i was so disappointed to know that i
couldn't stay in a piece of history
and got sent over to a motel
i was shocked at the decor that i saw it
was just hideous
it was brutal to hear that many guests
complain about a one-night experience in
the hotel
it actually scares you away when you see
the marquis that says thursday ladies
night and hiring part-time housekeeper
you don't want to advertise that you're
short on housekeeping
whose stupid idea was it advertised for
a part-time housekeeper and i guess it's
my idea i'll take the responsibility
thank you
can i ask you one question
would you come back and stay here please
raise your hands no never never
i appreciate your honesty thank you
thank
you
[Music]
you heard what the guests had to say
yeah yeah do me a favor spend a couple
of minutes here looking at what you've
inherited and ask yourself
do you really want it enough
do you really care enough
yes i do care
i don't think you do
[Music]
owner philip and general manager ginger
have just found out what the guests
really think about the monticello hotel
would you come back and stay here no
never
i think ginger has finally realized how
much philip's drinking is hurting the
hotel
and now she's asked to speak to me alone
because it's deep
his alcoholism is very deep
i can say he's being honest i've reached
out to my children
and they've all talked to him
but it hasn't been any good
and it's getting worse the stress on
my end has been
where is he at is he driving is he's
gonna kill somebody is he gonna kill
himself
i just wish she told me the truth that's
all i am a private person
this has been very hard
and it's hard to see someone destroy
themselves
i don't even think he realizes how bad
it is it's been a very heavy burden on
me
he's very ill it's a terrible disease
he's an old man and you're suffering the
consequences
[Music]
he needs help and that's the truth i'm
going to persuade him to get treatment
would you do that for me i will do that
i want this place to work
okay
thank you
and i'm sorry
[Music]
i'm going to need the staff's help to
get through to phillip
come through guys maybe together we can
break through his denial
i'm gonna get
philip in now
and i need you to get behind
agreeing that he needs help
i know it's hard
but you're part of this change
and you stand up for what you feel is
right
this staff needs him to show us
that
he's willing to make a change i think he
needs to become honest with himself
this
hotel
is a breaking point
and you need help
[Music]
is there anyone else in this room that
thinks that philip needs help with his
addiction please raise their hand
they're all here because each and every
one of them care
not just about the hotel but about you
ginger
you know
how bad
the drinking problem is yes i do
i pour out bottles i empty him out down
the sink
because i love him and i hate to see him
destroy himself and that's what it's
been like it's been very hard
if you could see it through our eyes
it's like night and day
during the day you just you're amazing
phillip you talk to us with so much
respect and stuff like that and as soon
as you start drinking you can see that
huge difference come over you it's like
a black cloud we really care about you
phillip
i mean we're afraid for you because your
rock bottom isn't going to be like most
because you have the money to pay your
way out you have the money to do what
you do your rock bottom is going to be
very serious it's either going to kill
you or kill somebody else and i don't
want to see you die and i don't want to
see you in trouble and hurt somebody
you're very important you're worth
getting clean you're so worth it
okay
philip
will you get
you help keep on hiding this i don't
know what you want me to say gordon what
about what you want to say
i'm not saying anything
we're done
if the entire staff can't get through to
phillip maybe speaking to him alone will
help change his mind he's got to get
help otherwise this place doesn't stand
a chance
when are you gonna snap inside and say
[ __ ]
i'm hitting rock bottom i've been in
this position for the past several years
i'm sorry to hear that don't get upset
don't get upset
[Music]
it's all part of it
so what you want to do phil
[Music]
are you ready to get help
please
i promise i'm definitely going
for my family for my staff i'm going
into treatment i appreciate that come
here it's time
some things in life are more important
than business and i'm glad philip has
realized he has to put his health first
and sort out his problems
change is in the air at the monticello
hotel so overnight my design team gave
the hotel the makeover it truly deserves
[Music]
good morning good morning
welcome to the new and improved
monticello hotel
before we go inside i want you to notice
something
that dreadful motel sign
has disappeared
when people want to make a booking you
can offer them a choice of the modern
annex or the historic hotel and that
will be a lot easier because i've opened
up four new suites for guests doubling
the number of rooms in this historic
hotel wow oh yes
let's go guys come here
have butterflies i am so excited to walk
in that hotel come jump in ladies
welcome to new suite
is it beautiful wow i love it oh my god
this is a beautiful room it should be
used for guests not storage
never my wildest dreams
did i think
our storage unit could end up looking
like this are you ready to see the
bedroom
that's so cool
i don't i don't have words gone is all
that secondhand furniture replaced by a
comfortable bed with luxurious linens
now we have something to be proud of i
mean the place is absolutely gorgeous
stunning new furniture beautiful linens
and beds for all your suites very classy
it's mind-blowing what gordon has done
is just phenomenal what do you think
i think that this is a room that i can
be proud to send my guests to oh my
goodness me wonderful of course they're
never going to want to leave no
no i'd like to show you my room
[Music]
it's amazing
for me the stunning interior
matches the majestic
exterior now you look on the outside you
think this is exactly the kind of fill
you want inside have a good look at the
bedroom
this one you're going to love oh boy
and the bed
as you know with the matches full of
stains now look that beautiful bed
that's what you call a proper king-size
bed oh wow it was our best room before
and now it's the best room in town
it's beautiful come through guys
the potential here
is phenomenal it's the heart of the town
again and something to be proud of
oh excuse me
welcome to monticello stunning new room
service oh
wow
how can a hotel of this standard not
have a small dynamic room service menu
increases the turnover i'll never check
but more importantly i guess stay
actually longer if they know the food's
that good in the room as well
now get yourselves a plate and start
tasting oh wow this is so good
those are rotten potatoes
yeah there's nothing like fresh salmon
that food was amazing i can't recall the
last time i tasted food so fresh
i think it's gonna be a real bonus enjoy
the rest of the food we've got a big big
night ahead of us it's a really nice
menu i think it's gonna bring the
revenue
higher this is exactly
what we needed this is sensational
mm-hmm
it's not just room service i've
reinvented the menu for the restaurant
too using the best local ingredients
i'm confident the combination of great
food and great rooms will encourage a
whole new generation to come here that's
getting medium in there it needs about
another minute or two then we'll pump
that one out okay the difference between
the frozen and the food we're getting
now night and day there is it's
indescribable for the taste the
presentation
it's awesome keep cooking with fresh
ingredients i will okay and
remember this the day a kitchen can't be
bothered to ball a [ __ ] egg yeah get
out of there okay you're better than
that yes sir good job thank you yeah
well done thank you are you checking in
yes yeah oh can i get your name uh sorel
oh you're staying in one of our new
suites i can't wait for people to see
these rooms oh wow and i'm ecstatic i'm
gonna have to send so many less guests
out to the motel this is what i had
hoped for
although the guests are delighted with
the changes it looks like chef dan has a
problem
quick word what's wrong
oh no you're leaving
the monticello's relaunch is going
brilliantly nice to see
gordon you okay yeah but chef dan has
just pulled me aside let's go
take a seat
listen
nine years clean and sober wow that's
phenomenal well done so i would love to
be a sponsor philip sponsor
if he would have me be a sponsor once he
gets out he's gonna need somebody by
side that's an amazing commitment
it's a real big responsibility to be
phil sponsor but it's one i'm willing to
take on and get our owner on the right
track yeah good job thank you
it's going to be a challenging journey
for philip but with all the support he
has from ginger and his staff i'm hoping
he'll be able to stay away from alcohol
so
when you get out of treatment you're
gonna need a sponsor somebody to take
your meetings so nine years
clean this over
if you want i offer
thank you
i appreciate it sounds good it does now
with new life breathe into the
monticello it's time for me to go
both of you
take care of yourselves
okay good luck thank you sir seriously
good luck oh dear next time i see you
give me a change man oh yes i will one
more thing before i go
what makes this place
very special it's not just it's a
historic building in its 90th year for
me it's the staff so
just so you don't forget it
here we are
a new plaque wonderful and the employers
of the month this month
are the entire staff
and you need to do more than just
recognize how good they are you need to
pay them properly yep ramsey did a
wonderful job the hotel is flowing in
the right direction
because i do have a good crew to turn
the ship back around and make it thrive
and i'm going to seek help
for my drinking thank you jordan
wow what a place
i really hope phillip keeps his promises
time will tell
since my visit to the monticello hotel
bookings have gone up this is really
nice
and with all the new revenue coming in
the staff are working with a new sense
of enthusiasm because philip is finally
paying them properly for all the hours
they've put in
gordon i want to thank you for what you
did you saved 50 people's jobs and their
livelihoods and their families
and phillip is booked into a treatment
program which starts next week all i can
say is for gordon is god bless you and
thank you